25 novembre sainte catherine patronne
des couturières dans les ateliers on le
coup plus on trinque on prépare des
volets verts et jaunes en cachette et en
distribuer des cadeaux sur fond de disco
et d'un merci patron à celles qui ont 25
ans chez hanae mori 3 catherinettes dont
une japonaise venue en stage à prendre
la mode à paris
mais où sont les fruits d'antan je pense
que la tradition se perd
et que il se passe moins de choses
maintenant le cas vu que c'est fait il y
avait autrefois des joies vraiment très
grande et toutes les maisons de couture
c'était kaffrine est ce type par an un
mois à la basse tous les ateliers ce
décor est
les ouvrières se déguisait chaque chaque
atelier avait un thème choisi et il y
avait des déguisements
suivant le thème choisi et c'était
vraiment extraordinaire
chris était toujours vert et jaune
c'était toujours vert et jaune comme les
chapeaux et après dans la journée on se
promenait sur les champs elysées c'est
vraiment la joie pour toute la journée
je suis dans le flou alors là tu avais
pourquoi vous porter un bonnet catherine
est
mais oui parce que j'ai 25 ans je suis
pas marié mais femme catherine qu'est-ce
qu'elle arrêtera sa ronde à l'origine du
10ème siècle
il ya une sainte catherine d'alexandrie
est en fête sainte catherine collard à
trois écolières
la tradition à vous dit que
les jeunes filles de l'école il ya plein
de métiers de brodeuses de couture
j'avais rapport aux toxines maintenait
la tradition de la sainte-catherine aux
évolutions de la salle lorsque j'étais
connu vous avez vous pas vous avez un
chapeau de catherine r non c'est pas
bien savoir seul cas fini a été
suffisant sied au 10ème siècle par le
supplice de la roue et visites lui savez
vous pourquoi vous fêter sainte
catherine
les jeunes filles et les rings mise je
crois entre l'âge de 25 ans et 35 ans
et chaque année fois fait sainte
catherine en libye en plaçant des
épargnes dans la coiffe un petit peu et
se marier et faisait un peu quand
allemand bismarck
il y a une autre tradition pour se
marier il faut aller toucher la statue
de sainte catherine au coin de la rue de
cléry de la rue montmartre
mais il convient de grimper à une
échelle et caïcos pensant japonais ils
ont des coutumes étranges ces français